Special, thanks to athletic greens,
the ultimate all in one nutritional supplement for supporting this video,
please see the link in the description to learn more.
I've always been very type a and so a friend of mine got me into cycling when I
was living in LA and I lived right on the beach in Santa Monica,
where there's this great bike path in the sand that goes for,
I think it's 25 miles in the sand, a 20 foot, no, hold on. Something like that,
the exact number doesn't matter.
But what I would do is I would go onto the bike path and I would get like head
down and push it as hard as I could.
I would go all the way to one end of the bike path and back, and then back home.
And I'd set my little timer when doing this huffing.
And puffing red face red.
Face, huffing it, but like just pushing it as hard as I can, every single,
you know, thrust of the leg. And, uh, of course, you know,
that may be quite fun if somebody was in my way on the bike path.
For sure. I'm like that. Guy's got places to go. So.
But I noticed it was always 43 minutes. I mean, you know, if you know,
Santa Monica, California, you know,
the weather is about exactly the same all year round.
So unless it was a surprisingly windy day,
it was always 43 minutes is what it took me to go as fast as I could
for that, on that bike path.
But I noticed that over time I was starting to feel less
psyched about going out on the bike path because just mentally,
when I would think of it, it would feel like pain and hard work.
It sounds like pain and heartbreak. Yeah. I mean, it was, but.
I guess at first that was okay. And after a while it just felt like, Oh,
I don't know, running the bike. Why don't I just hang out? Um,
so then I said, you know, that's not,
that's not cool for me to start to associate negative stuff with going on the
bike ride. Why don't I just chill for once? Like,
I'm just going to go on the same bike ride, but just, you know,
I'm not going to be a complete snail,
but I'll go at like half of my normal pace. So yeah,
I got on my bike and it was just pleasant.
I just went on the same bike ride more like standing up.
And I just noticed that I was, I was looking around more and,
and I looked out in the ocean. I noticed there that day,
there were these dolphins jumping in the ocean and I went down to Marina Del Rey
to my turnaround point. And um, Oh no, actually it was when the,
the breakers at Marina Del Ray,
there was a penguin that was flying above me. I was like, no way I looked up,
I was like, Hey, a penguin. And he in my mouth.
Was it a penguin or a publican? Oh, sorry, Pelican
penguin above me. I was like, what a, what did you take before your ride?
You had to see it a Pelican Pelican in your mouth. That's incredible accuracy.
Was that from like how far away was it like 20 feet up? Wow.
I don't know if he was accurate or I was, you know, so.
It is, I had such a nice time. It was just purely pleasant.
There is no red face. There was no huffing and puffing. I was just cycling.
It was nice. And when I got back to my usual stopping place,
I looked at my watch and it said 45 minutes.
And I was like, no way,
how the hell could that have been 45 minutes as compared to my usual 43?
It's like, there's no way. But yeah, it was right 45 minutes.
And that was like a profound lesson that I think changed the
way I've approached my life ever since is because I realized that I guess,
you know, what percentage of that huffing and puffing,
then we could do the math and whatever.
Over the 93 point something present of my huffing and puffing and all that red
face and all that stress was only for an extra two minutes.
It was basically for nothing. I mean, you know,
of course we're not talking about me competing in something where the huffing
and puffing might've been worth it, but for life,
I think of all of this optimization and getting the maximum dollar
out of everything in the maximum amount of every second to the maximum amount of
every minute. And I think I just take this approach now of going like, Oh,
or you could just take the lesson,
take most of that lesson and apply it and be effective and be happy.
You don't need to stress about any of this stuff.
And so honestly that's been my approach ever since I do things,
but I stopped before anything gets stressful.
[Inaudible].
All the time. What I would take. If I could only take one supplement,
the answer is invariably athletic greens.
I view it as all in one nutritional insurance. I recommended it. In fact,
in the four hour body,
this is more than 10 years ago and I did not get paid to do so with
approximately 75 vitamins minerals and whole foods sourced ingredients.
You'd be very hard pressed to find a more nutrient dense and comprehensive
formula on the market. It has multivitamins multi-mineral greens,
complex probiotics and prebiotics for gut health and immunity, formula,
digestive, enzymes, adaptogens, and much more.
I usually take it once or twice a day just to make sure I've covered my bases.
If I miss anything I'm not aware of,
of course I focus on nutrient dense meals to begin with that's the basis,
but athletic greens makes it easy to get a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available from travel packets.
I always have them in my bag when I'm zipping around,
it's also NSF certified for sport,
making it safe for competitive athletes as what's on the label is in the powder.
It is the ultimate all-in-one nutritional supplement bundle in one easy scoop.
And right now athletic greens is giving my audience that's you guys a special
offer on top of their all-in-one formula,
which is a free vitamin D supplement with your first subscription purchase.
Many of us are deficient in vitamin D,
which is usually produced in our bodies from sun exposure.
So particularly in the winter months,
adding a vitamin D supplement to your daily routine is a great option for
additional immune support.
Make an investment in your health today and try the ultimate all-in-one wellness
bundle, support your immunity,
gut health and energy by visiting athletic greens.com/t
F S you'll receive up to a year's supply of vitamin D for free with your first
subscription purchase. Again, that's athletic
greens.com/t F S as in Tim Ferriss show athletic
greens.com/tfs.